alex is on Twitter Dave does your
business value go into your net worth
evaluation yes your business is an asset
anything it's an asset goes into your
net worth
valuation net worth is assets minus
liabilities what you own that can be
turned into money that's an asset minus
what you owe
now if it's hard to turn into money that
just means it's an illiquid asset but
doesn't mean it's not an asset if it's
easy to turn into money quick that means
it's a liquid asset that's like just
taking money out of the bank that's
liquid your bank accounts liquid your
Real Estate's ill liquid hard to get
money out quick easy and so you know
assets are assets what you own minus
what you owe in my particular case well
in excess of half of my personal net
worth would be this business because it
has exploded I've got a lot of money and
real estate a lot of money in mutual
funds but this business has gone bananas
so the value my business is you know way
up there now could I sell it well I
don't even care I'm not gonna sell it
but it's easy to put a value on it
there's a valuation process on it that
you can use to value you know you know
multiples of your net profit multiples
of your gross revenues whatever you're
going to use even Book value which is
what all the things the business owns if
you just sold off all your inventory and
your buildings and receivables where
else that's called Book value at least
it's worth that that's the minimum that
it's worth but it's usually worth some
multiple of your net profits and that's
what you're looking for so good question
good question but yeah we're talking
when someone says someone is a
millionaire or a billionaire they are
not referring to income or they're not
supposed to be unless they're an
ignorant person okay because you know
when you hear all these politicians say
well he's not a million doesn't make a
million dollar zero that's an ignorant
politician I don't know what they're
talking about he's not a billionaire
he'd make a billion dollars a year it's
not how you measure millionaire
billionaire billionaire a millionaire is
based on its it's an accounting fun
it is net worth what you own minus what
you owe and so will million dollars
isn't quite enough anymore we weren't
discussing whether it's enough we were
discussing how to calculate it we can
discuss how to you know if you have a
million dollars in mutual funds net and
you have no debt then you know you can
tell what that's you know if it makes
eight percent that's eighty thousand
dollars a year and that's what you know
that millionaire if you're if you don't
own any real estate you don't own
anything else you just had a million
dollars in mutual funds being a
millionaire
says you'd have about an eighty thousand
dollar a year income is that enough but
ya know for most people that's enough is
that enough to buy seventeen cars and
have a hundred and ten foot yacht in the
Mediterranean no millionaires can't do
that they don't have the money so you
know what do you mean when you say
someone's rich if it's a hundred and ten
foot yacht that's a five hundred million
dollars or whatever or five hundred
thousand dollars or whatever you know
that that's one thing if that's what you
think of as rich then then you think of
rich is much more than a millionaire but
a millionaire is a really good place to
start there's about 11 million a
millionaire about 11 million
millionaires in America and if you can
get to there if you can have that as
your first big wealth financial goal
then that tells us from there you can do
a lot of stuff but you know and and
there are very precise data points that
tell us how you can become a millionaire
so if you had a business that was worth
five hundred thousand and you were 70
years old unless you sell the business
or take an income out of the business
after retirement that business doesn't
add much to your retirement even though
you would have a net worth of a million
dollars probably at that point so can
the assets create money starts to tell
you whether being a millionaire is
enough